lo que queremos es encontrar la derivada
de la función g
lo cual puede parecer un poco
intimidante al principio porque aquí
tenemos seno de x y coseno de x y luego
esta expresión un poco complicada
tenemos pi entre la raíz cúbica de equis
y luego toda esa expresión elevada al
cuadrado así es que si puede parecer un
poco intimidante al principio pero
tenemos ya todas las herramientas como
para poder encontrar fácilmente esta
derivada vamos a utilizar las
propiedades de las derivadas que
conocemos vamos a usar la regla de la
cadena que nos dice que la derivada con
respecto a x de x a la n es igual a n
por x elevada a la n 1 eso ya lo hemos
visto varias veces también vamos a
utilizar que la derivada con respecto de
x de coseno de x es igual a menos seno
de x
y que la derivada con respecto a x de
seno de x es igual a coseno de x y
únicamente utilizando esto podemos
encontrar la derivada de g
así es que pone pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo por tu cuenta ahora como
conocemos la derivada de seno de x y
también conocemos la derivada de kossen
vx seguramente lo más intimidante es
esta expresión de aquí así es que lo que
vamos a hacer es simplificar un poco
esta expresión para que te parezca más
familiar
vamos a hacerlo por acá a un lado
empezamos con pi sobre la raíz cúbica de
equis y todo esto elevado al cuadrado
esto es igual a pi al cuadrado sobre la
raíz cúbica de x elevada al cuadrado y
esto a que es igual bueno pues aquí
tenemos la equis y la estamos elevando a
la un tercio y después estamos elevando
la potencia 2 así es que esto es igual a
pi al cuadrado sobre y aquí no me voy a
saltar ni un solo paso porque es una
buena práctica de las propiedades de los
exponentes entonces aquí la raíz cúbica
de x es x elevada a la un tercio y luego
lo estamos elevando a la potencia 2 lo
cual a su vez es igual a pi al cuadrado
sobre x elevada a la dos tercios que es
igual a ti al cuadrado por x a la menos
dos tercios y ahora ya que lo escribimos
de esta forma ahora si tal vez podemos
pensar oye ahora si tengo una idea de
cómo podemos aplicar la regla de las
potencias con esta expresión esta
expresión complicada por acá es
simplemente pi al cuadrado por equis
elevada a la menos 2
tercios bueno pero ahora vamos a borrar
estas cuentas que hicimos por aquí así
es que ahora vamos a sacar la derivada
de cada uno de estos pedazos queremos
encontrar a g prima de x la cual va a
ser igual a de hecho podemos utilizar el
operador derivar por ejemplo podemos
poner por aquí el operador derivar con
respecto a x del lado izquierdo y
entonces también lo tenemos que hacer
del lado derecho así es que aquí vamos a
poner la derivada con respecto a x de
esta expresión menos la derivada con
respecto de x de esta otra expresión y
también la vamos a poner por acá
y entonces este término la derivada de 7
por seno de x pues esto va a ser
simplemente 7 por el coste no de x luego
por acá tenemos 3 por el coseno de x eso
va a ser igual a 3 por la derivada del
coseno de x pero por aquí tenemos un
signo menos estamos restando entonces
aquí tenemos menos 3 y ya que sacamos la
constante ahora si tomamos la derivada
del coseno de x la cual es menos seno de
x aunque la derivada del coste no de x
- seno de equis y ahora llegamos a este
último término que tenemos por aquí
arriba en amarillo y aquí ya nos queda
claro que podemos utilizar la regla de
la cadena entonces tomamos el exponente
menos dos tercios
y por cierto no se nos debe de olvidar
este signo menos que tenemos aquí
estamos restando esta expresión por lo
cual vamos a restar la derivada pero
bueno tenemos aquí el exponente menos
dos tercios lo multiplicamos por el
coeficiente que spears al cuadrado aquí
tal vez otra vez puedes sentir que es un
poco confuso tenemos pi al cuadrado y
ese es el coeficiente aunque sea pi
sigue siendo un coeficiente porque no
varía con respecto a x es simplemente un
número entonces lo que tenemos es el
exponente menos dos tercios
multiplicando al coeficiente
y al cuadrado
x elevada a la potencia menos dos
tercios menos uno y esto a cuánto es
igual
bueno pues tenemos kg prima de x es
igual a 7 por el coste no de x y luego
aquí tenemos menos 3 por menos seno de x
y eso es simplemente más
es por seno de equis y luego aquí
estamos restando un número negativo
entonces esto va a ser más
dos tercios por al cuadrado es igual a
dos y al cuadrado sobre tres
estos son estos dos términos
multiplicándose y luego multiplicamos
por equis a la menos dos tercios menos
uno eso lo podemos decir como menos un
entero y dos tercios o le podemos decir
menos cinco tercios equis a la potencia
menos cinco tercios y listo ya
terminamos teníamos aquí esta expresión
que se veía un poco complicada un poco
difícil de derivar pero utilizando la
regla de la cadena y lo que ya conocemos
que es la derivada del coseno y del seno
obtuvimos fácilmente la derivada de esta
función